tous étaient récoltées aurait ce matin
voilà ok parfait ce sera livrée cet
après midi chaque semaine julien gouache
fait le tour des exploitations
eurélienne pour faire le plein de
produits et pouvoir assurer les
commandes de son site internet mes
courses locales j'ai une tournée de
producteurs à aller voir en produits
frais à la commande je vais récupérer
les produits chez tous les producteurs
ou alors il ne me livre sur chartres
mais voilà c'est vraiment à la commande
par fait pas je le récupère au chalet ça
marche
depuis qu'il a lancé son activité au
mois d'avril il travaille avec une
trentaine de producteurs pour près de
300 produits proposés à la vente
diane pommard pratiquent la vente
directe sur son exploitation mais le
service de julien lui permet de toucher
plus de consommateurs
nous n'avons pas à faire juste à voir
toute cette partie vente logistique
préparation délégué moi je vais vivre
des légumes en encaisse en vrac et c'est
lui ensuite qui prépare ses petits
sachets pour ses clients donc
effectivement être installée à nogent le
fait ce fils et petit-fils d'agriculteur
propose aux particuliers de remplir
leurs paniers en ligne et de se faire
livrer à domicile
il laisse la liberté aux producteurs de
déterminer eux mêmes le prix de vente
ça permet de qu' il est l'heure juste
prix pour leur production et après comme
n'y a pas d'intermédiaire seulement mes
courses locales du coup ça te permet
ensuite au client d'avoir un prix
raisonnable
le vendredi c'est le jour des livraisons
le site compte une cinquantaine de
clients
bonjour livraison des courses locale
nous livrer ça nous fait gagner du temps
bien entendu c'est les invite à les
perdre une heure à faire les courses
voilà le jeune homme compte bien
développer son activité à long terme en
élargissant son champ de livraison et en
mettant en place des points relais pour
ses futures commandes